it's fun to imagine what the world was
like around the time we each entered it
we were too young to remember anything
but thanks to a detailed history of TV
ratings we know exactly which shows our
parents were bummed about missing
because they were too busy giving birth
to us or too tired from taking care of
us and they didn't have Hulu or Netflix
to use for ketchup purposes yeah our
parents were pretty much savages but
what were they watching on TV 1972 to
1976 all in the family the social
upheaval of the late 60s gave way to
more social upheaval in the 70s and lots
of families family time suddenly
consisted of parents arguing with their
liberal offspring about various
hot-button topics all on the family
appealed to both sides most of the
actions centered around Carole
O'Connor's Archie Bunker a gruff but
unexpectedly lovable bigot who butted
heads with his hippie daughter and her
husband while wife Edith tried to keep
the peace all on the family was one part
sitcom one part public affairs
discussion one part moving drama and
it's so resonated with Americans that
had stayed atop the ratings all the way
into the disco era 1977 happy days
Americans in the mid 70s came down with
a bad case of nostalgia for the late 50s
and early 60s in her happy days a
throwback about the wholesome Cunningham
family The Andy Griffith Show 'he's
child star and future oscar-winning
director Ron Howard played wide-eyed
high schooler Richie Cunningham who hung
out at Arnold's diner with friends like
Arthur Fonzie Fonzarelli who was quite
possibly the coolest character on
television he wore a leather jacket rode
a motorcycle could make a jukebox play
by hitting it and summoned young girls
with a snap of his fingers they were
different times
[Applause]
[Music]
1978 to 1979 Laverne and Shirley a rare
example of a spin-off doing as well as
the show it was spun off from Laverne
and Shirley were first introduced in an
episode of happy days then got their own
sitcom penny Marshall's Laverne was edgy
Cindy Williams Shirley was a bit more
optimistic they were roommates best
friends and co-workers at the shots
brewery in the late 50s and early 60s
bubbling with energy Laverne and Shirley
balanced their time at the bottling
plant while hanging out at laverne's
father's restaurant and fending off the
advances of their nerdy and obnoxious
friends 1980 1983 1992 to 1994 60
minutes 60 minutes has been a part of
the CBS lineup since 1968 and the show's
in-depth reporting made it a pioneer in
TV news it's produced a few moments of
world-changing journalism such as Mike
Wallace's 1996 story about tobacco
industry whistleblower Jeffrey wagon
but perhaps 60 minutes most famous
segment has been the show ending palate
cleanser a few minutes with Andy Rooney
in which the veteran humorously
complained about whatever he felt like
but not sleeping is not my problem
Justin Bieber Lady Gaga and Usher I mean
who when did bright colored plastic cows
pigs and rabbits get to be art I don't
like most of the stuff passing for art
and it's everywhere 1981 1982 and 1984
Dallas primetime soaps were the biggest
TV fad in the late 70s and early 80s and
the biggest of the ball was Dallas it
centered around the Ewing family and
their massive Texas based oil company
headed by Larry hagman's downright evil
jr. Ewing it also produced one of the
most watched TV events ever the two-part
who shot jr. cliffhanger that got people
tuning in the following season 1985
dynasty by 1985 the popularity of Dallas
had diminished but audiences still
wanted to see rich people behaving badly
on prime-time television ABC happily
obliged with dynasty starring John
Forsythe as tycoon Blake Carrington ad
in a much younger secretary turned wife
as well as Joan Collins as Blake's
ex-wife Alexis and the show discovered
exactly what people wanted to see Alexis
and her new rival
getting into arguments then slapping
each other while wearing extremely
expensive clothes 1986 to 1990 The Cosby
Show with the recent allegations against
Bill Cosby it's easy to forget his show
was once so well-loved debuting on NBC
in 1984 when the popularity of sitcoms
was fading The Cosby Show was crafted to
be a groundbreaking portrayal of a black
family something that was rarely seen on
TV The Cosby Show often played fast and
loose with sitcom standards and in doing
so changed viewers expectations some
episodes tackled heavy subject matter
while others had almost no plot at all
and just featured the family hanging out
and showing how great it was for a
family to be together it all came
together to make The Cosby Show an
unstoppable juggernaut 1990 Roseanne The
Cosby Show wasn't alone as the most
viewed show on TV in 1990 it also had to
contend with Roseanne another show that
broke new ground in television
representation rarely had anyone
attempted a show about a blue-collar
Midwestern family with two working
parents but Roseanne was also the anti
Cosby Show built around a family with
financial struggles messy lives and real
world problems that never resolved at
the end of an episode through it all
they still managed to stay a close-knit
family it was such an indelible portrait
of this particular kind of American
family that ABC revived Roseanne for a
short-lived 2018 run more than 20 years
after it initially went off the air 1991
cheers cheers was so different from
other contemporary sitcoms when it
debuted in 1982 it was nearly canceled
before taking home some Emmys in 1983 by
1989 everyone was invested in what
became the nation's favorite
neighborhood bar and the cast of
characters who frequented it it was so
popular in fact that it led to the also
successful spin-off Frasier launched the
career of Woody Harrelson and gets a
shout out in scores of pop-culture
references 1995 and 1998 Seinfeld
finally after years of shows about
things along came a show about nothing
except that Seinfeld was about something
the hilariously dark and selfish
impulses of some nasty New Yorkers based
on Jerry Seinfeld's scattered
observational comedy it turned into one
of the most intricately written and
inventive sitcoms ever made
it also upended the traditional sitcom
formula by featuring bizarre classic
moments like ordering from The Soup Nazi
and messing up an operation by dropping
a Junior Mints
Americans love the cleverly written
storylines that somehow all connected at
the end and it beat everything else on
the air 1996 to 1997 and 1999 er the
fast paced ultra realistic drama ER
marked another shift in viewer tastes
breaking up the life and death tension
of a big-city emergency room were scenes
involving the doctor's personal lives
moments that were just as captivating
thanks to stars like George Clooney
julianna margulies and Noah Wyle ER was
a mainstay of NBC scheduled for 15
seasons and at times it was the
most-watched show on TV
[Music]